[Music]
this week on fyi don't shame and bully
people like us in a special report we
hear an appeal from the young people who
rely on food banks there were a few
people who would make comments
oh you can't eat enough you must be poor
and we'll be heading almost two miles
down in the icy waters of antarctica to
check out an unbelievable shipwreck
discovery
[Music]
this is fyi and as the war in ukraine
continues millions of people are still
fleeing the country to safety but
millions of ukrainians are also staying
behind to fight the russian forces
others are struggling to find a safe
route out as cities and towns are being
bombed at all times of the day and night
we were sent video diaries from some
children that are still in the country
[Music]
these children live in kamilnitsky in
central ukraine which has escaped
intense bombing
they do long distance online learning in
the morning and the rest of their day is
spent volunteering to help the military
making things like camouflage nets
it's changed my life it's changed my
life
i feel fear every day and i'm scared for
my parents and friends
and i really want to go to school see my
friends again go for a walk on the
weekends and enjoy my life
i want to do something useful for my
military so we can win the war
staying at home and doing nothing is
boring
and we need to help the military and all
the other people
meanwhile anastasia was forced to stay
in a shelter in the city of hardkiv for
eight days before she managed to travel
to a safer city further west in ukraine
i was staying in the bomb shelter for
eight days and that was really crazy
all the time you hear bombs and
buildings are getting destroyed near to
your bomb shelter and if you get on the
streets
you can be just killed and that's crazy
because it's happening in 21st century
but now i'm in levious and i'm safe and
i'm really thankful i'm staying with my
friends right now and of course i feel
kind of guilt of leaving my hometown and
moving to live but now i can be helpful
and not stay only in the bomb shelter
we're helping people at the local
railway station
and also
we help refugees to get to the borders
and escape from the country because
people are really afraid
if you don't get why russia invaded
ukraine and want to know more about how
world leaders are trying to end the war
check out our explainer just head to our
webpage first dot news forward slash fyi
and click on the i don't get it link
now our series of conversations that
give us kids a voice on some of the big
issues returns to fyi it's a
conversation like no other it's
conversation
when we heard that an increasing number
of young people are being bullied or
made to feel embarrassed for using food
banks we felt it was time for those who
used them to have their say
we always struggled
my mom was working a lot but she just
wasn't earning enough to supply for us
all
[Music]
there have been times that we've not had
as much to eat as what we normally would
of
and as like knows my parents have a new
team
it was quite difficult to get food
especially as we're in a rural area and
quite isolated from supermarkets
for some people is it a stigma of being
judged about going to a food bank and
that can put people off
2.5 million british children live in
food poverty
we speak from experience
my local food bank supports my family
we also volunteer here
this is the place where all of the food
is actually stored and the food that's
most needed
is things such as tinned foods toilet
bowls basic things that people need
every day okay thank you very much thank
you
[Music]
my family we didn't really
have to ask for help people would notice
that we're struggling because the food
ranks run by members of the church you
went to
but i know for some people it can
actually be
a daunting to go into a food bank
because they might not want to say
yeah we're struggling it's definitely
something that people get unnecessary
hate and i think that kind of prevents a
lot of people who maybe are it as well
from going to the food bank and opening
up about it
i was bullied in school so i already
worried what people would think of me
people did say
oh why aren't you eating anything so i
was really embarrassed about that
there were a few people who would make
comments oh you can't eat enough you
must be poor
and
and they'd tell everyone about it
one of my sisters is three and she is
currently going through chemotherapy
it costs quite a lot to try and travel
back and forth from hospitals my dad
ended up having to stop working and that
that's made it like quite difficult for
us
[Music]
it became harder to i actually get what
we'd normally buy
with it being a relatively big family as
well
and it just became a lot harder
i've noticed times where my parents
would have gone without food
and to make sure that we couldn't
and parents shouldn't have to make that
decision of whether they're going to eat
that night or whether their children are
[Music]
prices of healthy food and much higher
than unhealthy and affordable food you
don't have enough money it adds a lot of
health risks to it people are going to
go for the options that are cheaper
because then they're not spending as
much money but they're still like
managing to eat at school
me and my sister run free school meals
my sister was trying to get the pasta
but because the pasta had vegetables in
she was charged an extra 16p
towards the meal
it's not very good
that even though you're on free school
meals you still have to pay
towards vegetables so you have a
healthier diet
when i was in primary school we didn't
get much help at all i was struggling to
eat at school and stuff my mom was
working a lot but she just wasn't
earning enough so it was a lot of
not being able to scrape enough money
because of bills and stuff it's very
stressful when you know you can't eat
anything but you're very hungry as well
it's definitely
distracting because you're more focused
on your stomach than the lesson
i've i've been told off before for not
focusing enough because i was hungry
once we didn't know what that free
school meals existed so when my mom did
find out about them and she knew that
she was able to apply that definitely
helped
i think the pandemic has shown how
volatile jobs are and how important it
is to put yourself in someone else's
shoes before you say something or write
something on the internet
before the pandemic food banks were
already heavily relied on so now that
the pandemic has been thrown into it and
people are struggling to earn money
because of that it's gotten 10 times
worse
[Music]
hi
guys i'm from a very big family there's
nine of us all together and when we're
all together we have to get a bit hectic
[Music]
during the pandemic the availability of
certain food became a lot more difficult
being my dad being on furlough certainly
didn't help either
it was quite difficult to get food
especially as we're in a rural area and
quite isolated from
um from other from like main stores and
supermarkets
it was very lucky that we had like a lot
of support from people in the community
who would help us out if needed
i think we all have a responsibility in
a role to play in making sure that no
one goes hungry especially in the
country that's one of the seven richest
in the world the work their food that
food bank's done is incredible and
really needed in the community they're
there when people need help in a rental
crisis and they need help
but it's not a long-term solution i
would probably say to someone in the
same situation that i was in don't worry
about the stigma
just get the help that you need
because it's easier to get help
than to struggle and i don't want anyone
else to go through that
and those people who judge you maybe in
a few years time they might need help
so just don't worry about it
like as you said getting what you need
is what matters
to check out more conversations on big
issues like racism bullying and being a
young carer head to our webpage first
dot news forward slash fyi
so maya do you know what this is i think
it's a film reel right it is now
everything is done digitally now these
guys
they're recording onto a memory card but
back in the day this is how they used to
record film so what happened to the
stuff that was recorded onto film
because of course everything's on
computers or uploaded into the cloud
right well scala is at the british film
institute national archive checking it
out
i'm at the bfi's master film store where
some of the oldest and most precious
reels of film are kept to find out how
they're preserved and the amazing things
they're doing with these films i'm about
to enter a special vault that's kept at
minus five degrees i'm not kidding and
bryony here is going to show us around
you can really feel the cold
so why do the reels of film have to be
kept in such cold conditions
well film deteriorates sort of naturally
so we keep it very cold
which just stabilizes everything and
kills all the bugs
so that it will last for hundreds of
years so can we see one up close yeah
well we can go in the vault and see
where they live anyway
oh my gosh it's freezing
this is where the cans live in in the
cold
and one of them has a really interesting
story right it does it's
saved from a ship wreckage in antarctica
over a hundred years ago absolutely if
they were on an expedition to antarctica
the ship got trapped in the ice and sank
and the guy who is making the film of
the expedition
saved it so this is the actual can
of film oh my gosh that's the real one
i'm very careful because he's a very
fragile it's a hundred years old so that
was
in antarctica a hundred years ago oh my
gosh would you like to see a cliff of
the film that'd be amazing okay let's go
but it's not just about preserving reels
of film the bfi turns them into digital
film on computer drives this is so
historians tv and film producers can use
the footage for new projects and archive
documentaries from long ago can get a
whole new generation of viewers
the latest resort film that's been
released is south so this is the famous
explorer surrender shackleton who went
down to antarctica on
to try and cross over the whole of the
continent of antarctica and he went on
his ship the endurance
with 28 men
and they then got stuck in the ice they
had bad luck and did they all survive it
was extremely difficult journey but they
did eventually all get back
so who was it who actually filmed the
voyage so the guy who films the voyage
is a guy called frank hurley and he was
employed by the expedition as the
official photographer there has really
never been a film
that has bettered this about antarctica
the image is absolutely stunning why is
the work of the bfi so important
well if you imagine you could
invent a machine
that would go back and travel through
time like doctor who's tardis
i mean imagine how cool that would be to
go 100 years ago and go to antarctica
and that's what you would be looking at
you know it's like a window into another
time
[Music]
nice one scarlett now we've got an
exciting update
this is sir ernest shackleton ship
endurance and it's just been found
nearly two miles down after it sank over
a century ago
the search mission was headed up by tv
historian dan snow and he sent us this
video of how they found the ship
[Music]
this is one of the most significant
shipwreck finds in recent history i
think it will seize the world's
imagination like the finding of the
titanic did back in the day
the day after endurance sank in november
1915 the capstone joints made a sighting
using this sextant and a sun and he gave
an estimation of where the ship sank
that proved unbelievably accurate
it was found using sidescan sonar we've
got the world's most advanced underwater
vehicles on this ship
[Music]
people said we couldn't do it people
said the conditions down here were too
tough but we did the wreck appears to be
in one big piece largely just as it was
last seen before it sank in november
1915. it is so cold down there and there
are no wood eating microorganisms down
there at all so the wreck is it's as if
it's been frozen in time it's been
preserved we are leaving the wreck
exactly as we found it we are not
touching it we're not taking anything
from it the only thing we are taking is
data we're taking a laser scan means a
model of the wreck can be reproduced to
centimeter accuracy we are using
techniques that have never been used at
that depth before to bring back the most
accurate picture possible of that wreck
thanks for that dan
now we're going to end on some positive
news about ukraine yes sir we think it's
amazing to see the warm welcome
ukrainian refugee children are getting
as they try to start their new life in
other countries
and we really love this video that went
viral of a little boy's first date his
new school in spain see you next
[Music]
wait a week